Speaker 1: There is a new report that Donald
Trump is spending days workshopping nicknames
for Ron DeSantis. Now, I have to tell you, this is
not a story about, oh, it's another Trump rumor.
This is genuinely a smart thing to do
this with where the Republican Party is.
Coming up with the best possible nickname with
which to brand and stigmatize. Ron DeSantis
is a good use of time for Trump. A lot
of the things Trump spends time on are
completely useless. But this makes sense.
There's an article in the Hill. Trump spends
days workshopping nicknames for DeSantis.
Former President Trump has made developing
nicknames for his Republican rival and potential
presidential opponent Ron DeSantis a priority as
his team works on his 2024 campaign, according
to a new Bloomberg report. Trump has floated run
dishonest Ron the establishment and tiny
D as monikers for the Florida governor,
but appears to favor Ron to sanctimonious.
Trump coined the sanctimonious ahead of the
midterm elections and shortly before launching his
own presidential bid. So let's talk about this.
Trump is terrible at a ton of things. As I said
earlier, he is good at making fun of people.
That's the reality he's good at nicknaming people.
He's good at stigmatizing people. And when you
are potentially going to be fighting someone as
uncharismatic and seemingly unable to handle your
style of attack as Ron DeSantis, one of the best
things you can do is nickname him with something
that will really titillate and sincerely and
hope that he is unable to respond in kind. Now,
the problem with this sanctimonious is I don't
think a lot of Republican voters necessarily know
what it means. And of course, it is actually
accurate, which is when you're sanctimonious,
you make a show out of being or appearing morally
superior to others. Ron DeSantis does do that. You
need only look at his State of the State address
from yesterday that he gave in Florida to confirm
that. But I don't know that a lot of Republican
voters necessarily know what sanctimonious means.
So Tiny D is pretty interesting. And there's also
this high heels story. I don't know. This is so
insane that this is where the Republican Party
is. But Ron DeSantis for a while has been wary.
It's I it's I laugh because it's crazy that this
is where we are in American politics. DeSantis has
been wearing high heeled cowboy boots for a while,
but now there is a new suspicion that he's also
wearing lifts inside the boot, which, by the way,
Trump is also suspected of wearing. Don't think
the sanctimonious is the only guy doing this.
So Ron DeSantis officially is only five nine.
But there are images of him looking as tall as
people who are known to be over six feet tall. So
of course, the idea would be DeSantis puts a lift
inside the boot and then wears a high heel that
he looks six one and people think he's taller than
he actually is. All of this stuff really matters.
Tall candidates tend to do better now. Do they
tend to do better because they're tall? Well,
that's a different question. We'd have to look at
that in a different way. But it wouldn't surprise
me if Trump focused in on some kind of nickname
that related to DeSantis actually being short
or. I mean, listen, I'm five nine also 5755959.
At least that's what my license says, let's put
it that way. And then, you know, sort of being
desperate to be six feet tall and wearing high
heels and cowboy boots. I don't know where it's
going, but it wouldn't surprise me that it goes
in that in that direction. Again, I believe that
the Santos is 100% worse than Trump. Adam Schiff
had a different feeling yesterday, which was
that Trump really is the danger. I think Trump's
incompetence actually makes him less dangerous
and that he's less able to accomplish things.
The Santos is completely uncharismatic,
completely uninspiring as a speaker,
but he would pose a real threat of getting some
really dangerous stuff done. So if I had to pick,
I actually do think. The Democratic
candidate is better off facing Trump.
And the risk of a Trump presidency is lower
than that of a decent this presidency.
Continuing to take opinions from you
in the audience about that question